Iran is pushing back against President
Trump after his angry Twitter message
targeting the Tehran government the
president used capital letters to warn
Iran's president not to threaten the
u.s. the Iranian Foreign Ministry said
this morning there would be equal
countermeasures if the US tries to block
Iran's oil exports Elizabeth Palmer
who's in London has reported extensively
from Iran Elizabeth good morning good
morning
as you say Iran has responded to the
administration's aggressive language
with threats of its own but behind the
tough talk the government is really
worried about US sanctions of course but
also and maybe most importantly about
internal unrest we were in Iran in May
when the u.s. pulled out of the nuclear
deal and of course there were the usual
staged death to America demonstrations
but there was also a wider undercurrent
of anger among ordinary people furious
with Iran's own leadership with a lousy
economy with unemployment with
corruption you name it now the Iranians
who have joined public protests that
have popped up here and there in the
past few months are the ones Secretary
of State Pompeo suggests should rise up
and overthrow the regime the trouble is
they could die trying we saw in 2009 how
the hardliners responded to those crowds
demanding change most Iranians want
evolution they don't want another
revolution certainly not one
orchestrated by America so really we've
arrived at a pretty dangerous impasse
John no Elizabeth thanks